o óleo de coco extravirgem é saudável e
deve ter um aroma suave e característico
de coco aqui que tá o problema de acordo
com os produtores de coco no Brasil é
melhor evitar aqueles rotulados como sem
aroma ou sem sabor pois esses passaram
por um processo de refino de refinamento
e tiver os componentes essenciais do
Coco extraídos incluindo muitos os
ácidos grassos que tornam Esse óleo tão
especial e benéfico paraa nossa saúde o
óleo de coco do tipo refinado branqueado
e desodorizado que também não tem sabor
cor cheio passa por diversos processos
químicos para ser produzido por exemplo
a neutralização de componentes que
eliminam odor e cheiro involve o uso de
substâncias como a soda cáustica nesses
os a quantidade de ácidos grassos de
cadeia média podem aparecer muito baixa
ou até mesmo com zero parecendo como
zero nos rótulos então para ajudar na
sua saúde utilize o óleo de coco extra
virgem comum e se possível orgânico